nobody's going to save you but you you  know I can't rely on the government I  can't rely on my dad I can't rely on  anyone to provide for me you know I  don't come from money maybe if I was  super rich but I'm not like how do I  survive I don't like where I come from I  come from a little town just outside of  London there's no men there that I like  there's no women that I want to be  friends with so what do I do do I just  wait to be saved no I'm wasting my life  just sitting there I need to make some  money so I can get out and live the kind  of life that I want to live okay so now  I've made some money I can be in Miami  where I have access to better men better  women better conversations like this